hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my YouTube and Facebook
viewers cozy blankets who was in the
partnership with her business with her
husband and is finding that they
disagree on how to grow the business and
one of my advice on how to work out
partnerships so with my experience right
now I'm the only owner in Evan
Carmichael calm in my previous
businesses I've had partners and my wife
also owns her own business and I'm
almost a partner in that business turns
up giving advice and trying to help her
out with her company as well it's
especially hard when you're married to
your partner because there's a whole
other set of issues that you know come
in these up beyond just the business
part of it but usually what I found in
any kind of partnership situation if
you're married or not is you have one
person who's a little bit more you know
aggressive and wants to grow and has
risked your ideas and the other person
is a little bit more play it safe
risk-averse conservative doesn't want to
try as many new things there's worried
about the downside so you have the
worrier and the optimist it's typically
how it works out with a lot of different
partnerships so I don't know which one
you are if you're the warrior if you're
the optimist but what you need to do
then my experience in working with
partnerships versus understand the other
person's you got to sit down understand
where they're coming from you know try
to explain your part listen to to what
they're saying you know really carefully
try to get a really firm grasp of why
they're concerned with what you want to
do versus what they want to do and then
the next thing I would do is try to
start it on a small scale so whatever
big idea you have that you want to go
after start small start it on a really
small scale something that you can see
if it works you commit really minimal
time and budget to it especially the
money side you that's what's more of the
concern than the time we're gonna spend
all this money on stuff that's not going
to work out so try to get it started
without spending a lot of money or
without spending any money just your
time and see if you can build a little
bit of momentum I know with my wife's
business I encourage you to do a whole
bunch of stuff and we slowly get into
things she's definitely the more
conservative person and I'm the more
let's try something out and I'll try a
whole bunch of stuff with my business
and we'll have a whole bunch of failures
and then the ones that really work I'll
give to her and say hey this work for me
you should go and try and it can
hopefully work for you and again you
start on a small scale and then build it
up so that's the best strategy that I
would give you a start small find a way
to make it work finally way to make it
start generating some attention a
certain generating some revenue and
build it up from there the other thing
that can help is if you show case
studies so if you show other companies
that have done it before if you know you
see me giving advice work for me you can
say well work for Evan so let's give it
a shot or whoever else you look up two
if it's a famous entrepreneur or
something else you've read online show
that its work with somebody else and
it's a lot easier to kind of convince
them to want to take that first step but
again some step one the small step
launch it you know might fail we locked
a ton of different things than never
chemical calm and Muslim don't go
anywhere it's a whole bunch of small
test and then you see the ones that are
working and you start to expand those
and the ones that don't work then you
shut them down and move on to new things
so you want to encourage trying out new
things as long as it's not so risky that
it could sink your company because
they're spending a lot of money on it or
all of your time on it I hope that helps
if you guys liked the video please give
it a thumbs up I love seeing those comes
in makes me want to make more of these
videos few guys and it I'd love to hear
how you work with your partner if you
want to leave a comment under the video
or if you have anything else to share
please leave a comment below and we'll
see you on the next episode
you